yeah okay so thank you for being here
and i wish to thank georgio and the
organizer for letting me giving this
talk it's a real pleasure
and so number one is monash university
it's the place i'm coming from number
two is i'm here and number three
is where i'm going to be so yeah
so i'm going to be back in italy next
year and we will see something about
stress and conjecture so stress and name
has appeared many many times so he has
been lingering
in the room for all these three days
and finally we are going to see what the
conjecture is and then eliza is going to
tell something on the conjecture from a
completely different perspective this is
my understanding it's going to be
different because basically we will
speak about special tensors which are
symmetric tensors so homogeneous
polynomials so this is my
idea
and this is not
so we started these
very basic things so multiplication of
two by two matrices hopefully there is
no mistake so please don't check
so just look at a nice color
black blue magenta and red and
if you look at it you see that well we
need eight elementary operation addition
and multiplications if we want to
perform
this operation and it's
well don't look at it i just said it
before
and then there is this tensor t which is
representing the multiplication of two
by two matrices and the idea is that the
first c4 dual is just selecting a's the
second one is selecting b's and the last
c4 is just a placeholder which is
telling you which element of the
target matrix you are computing so this
is very natural we know
very well about this
and in terms of notation we can just
write down
t and frank again please just look at
the colors so there is black blue and
the three
four colors each color is representing
an entry of the matrix so you see in
black is c11 blue you have c12 and so on
and you have eight summons so this is
why we say unit eight elementary
operation and each of this summon is
what we call an elementary tensor or it
has been called also primitive tensor
simply means is the simplest tensor you
can produce because it's product of
vectors so you don't have addition
involved so this is a very basic notion
and t is written using eight of them
and this is a very usual thing
instruction in 1969 basically proved
that you can just use seven elementary
tensors
and if i got the
story right
he basically was trying to show that
eight is optimal
and he didn't manage two and then he
realized i think just by good luck that
well you can do a seven
and how did he do this well
basically is a change of basis so
you can write t using the following
summons so number one is just because
red is the first summon
and you see that what's different from
what we did before is that each of these
vectors you're going to compute the
tensor product of are now
uh some of what we used before so you
perform some linear linear operation and
then you have the second summon and then
you keep going and you finish with seven
summons what is really good about this
expression is that each of the seven
lines only three you can see so
there is no mistake possible because you
don't know what is here
so there is nothing wrong in what i
wrote and what is good is that each line
is only involving one elementary tensor
so it's just involving one
multiplication in some sense and so you
managed to write the same tensor we
wrote before using eight
using seven elementary tensors and this
is
what i understand stress and result to
be why do you call this a change with
basis
oh
just a way for me to remember what i
want to say it's just that you change a
little bitty element to use it's not
precise it's just an idea it's probably
not very appropriate but just you recall
me what i want to say
okay remind me sorry okay and mother
thames doesn't show that the tensor rank
of t is at most seven
and this was a breakthrough result at
the time for basically two reasons so
reason number one is that e-mail
allowed this result allowed to
the
development of faster algorithms for
matrix multiplication not just two by
two but
and by end by making them of even size
and then splitting them in blocks
and it was really relevant in the 60s
because
i think that
performing operation was the real
obstacle it was not easy to perform
multiplication perform many of them was
difficult so even a little bit of saving
was very good
nowadays i'm not an expert in
computational mathematics it looks like
what everyone is concerned with is the
curse of dimensionality so you're not
worried so much with computing but with
storing so in some sense trusting result
in this version is not really good
because it requires you to
pre-compute and store information and
then to perform the operation
and now in computational mathematics
they prefer to compute a lot more rather
than storing a lot of information so
this is why maybe this is not the
biggest contribute we can draw from this
result but the second contribute is
still relevant and basically was saying
to people well even if you are
considering a very straightforward
algorithm something you think you know
very well multiplying two by two
matrices is easy
well there are surprises maybe the
computational complexity whatever you
want to denote with that is not what you
expect so you have to be very careful
when you want to decompose stencils or
find optimal algorithm yep just to
comment on your first comment uh
strassen actually moves less data can be
organized to move less data than
standard matrix multiplied so it can be
organized because also moving data is
another problem not only storing them
but moving them between these parallel
clusters things yeah okay thank you
okay and so here comes the conjecture
basically in 1973 about the
multiplication of two by two matrices
and in some sense it was basically
telling you well i have two pairs of
matrices a b and c d and i want to
multiply them
and what is the best way of doing this
is this
just a trivial thing i first multiply a
times b and then i multiply sinc c times
d and i'm done
or there is an interesting way of
entangling the two multiplication in
such a way you can save you can perform
in a better way so basically this is the
idea i see underlying the conjecture and
if you want to be more on the physiolog
philosophical side we can say well you
have an algorithm and this algorithm is
optimal in performing a task you want to
perform the task twice
and you ask yourself is the best way
just to apply twice the same algorithm
or there is a way to devise something
better
and there is at least one nice example i
spoke with this with
jm about cooking pasta so i'm italian i
should be able to say something about
this so if you want to cook pasta you
make the water boil after the water it
was boiling you put the salt
and then you put the pasta you wait for
the appropriate amount of time get rid
of the water and then you have your dish
of pasta but suppose that luke is coming
to visit you you want to cook two dishes
of pasta
then what you have to do just repeat
twice the same process or maybe use more
water more salt
and then maybe if you're mixing kind of
pasta it's
difficult because you have to time in a
different way but maybe this is more
efficient you save energy maybe you save
water so it's not so immediate to
understand what the best thing is and jm
is another example about changing
diapers to two babies something like
that and as i'm here without my wife and
my daughter i don't want to think about
that just for one week so i don't speak
of that example too but there are just
funny examples to uh
get you have the idea of what the
problem is so so how is this a
conjecture
or something you could decide
and this is how you can decide from my
point of view this is the version what i
call the conjecture is in terms of
tensors
in independent set of variables so you
take just vector spaces v1
it was a it was a question can you do
this
the question is
oh sorry sorry sorry you're right the
conjecture is that you cannot do in a
better way you're perfectly right okay
now i understand what you mean sorry so
the conjecture is that you cannot
multiply the two pairs in a more
efficient way if you know exactly what
is the best for each pair yeah thanks
now i understand what you mean yeah i
was distracted by the pasta cooking
i'm not hungry anymore
so this is the one version we can use is
using tensor so you can make it in some
sense more precise
and independent set of variables means
that these vector spaces do not share
anything in common
and again we use a notion of tensor rank
using elementary tensor so you have your
tensor ti and the rank is a number which
is telling you which what is the least
number of tensors elementary tensor you
have to use to write it as a sum of them
and then
you can look at this expression clearly
if you take the sum of the ti you can
write it using
as many tens elementary tensor as the
sum of the ranks because i can write
each ti using that many you put all of
them together you get a long long
expression this you can do and the
question is can you do better
and so
the conjecture is that you can't so they
are equal so if the ti's are in
different center variables the best you
can do is just a trivial thing they
compose each summon separately and this
is the best
and this is how you phrase the
conjecture then you can ask yourself now
that it is a conjecture thinking thank
frank you can ask yourself is it true or
false
and you can make up your mind if you
believe is true or false and since i
have been working on this i am changing
each two weeks my opinion maybe it's
true maybe it's false depending on what
we manage to do and when you find a
problem you see well maybe i can
construct a country example and then you
manage to solve it or your friend
managed to do that so then you believe
it's true so it depends if you're
optimistic or
pessimistic and in life it goes up and
down but i think that in general among
experts there is no
common
agreement about that if it is false or
true so it's really open can be in some
sense both of them we don't know it
would be a surprise in any way and it
would be really nice to see how it is
working and as this is so difficult
there is also this approximated version
which in some sense we saw many many
times and this is based on the notion of
border rank everyone knows what it is
basically
you want to write t as a sum of t
tensors depending on some parameter
lambda
and taking the limit you get the t you
want without the limit you don't so you
can do better in this way sometimes this
is what you
expect and the conjecture in this case
is known to be false
so if you look at border ranks the
border rank of the sum can be smaller
and this is important because
discovering that it can be smaller
allows you to construct faster say more
efficient algorithm requiring
less elementary operation
and there is also another version of the
conjecture which we can call the
symmetric conjecture
and basically
this is based on the fact that symmetric
tensors are a relevant example
and they are just homogeneous
polynomials so they are in some sense
easier to treat you have more tools
especially from commutative algebra and
algebraic geometry to deal with them and
this makes it possible to get more
results so the idea is that well try
this version of the conjecture if you
can decide this one then you can try and
study the general one but keep in mind
that they are not the same thing
because the symmetric tensor rank and
the rank are not known to be equal even
for symmetric tensor this is common
conjecture so it's not solving the same
problem but if you get some
way of doing this there is good hope you
can try and go for the general thing
so you just introduce your
forms an independent set of variables
and the worrying wearing rank is just
the semantic tensor rank just for
historical reason this is the way i call
it and you define it in the most natural
way simply you replace elementary tensor
with symmetric elementary tensors and
they are just these power of linear
forms so this is how you can define the
varying rank
and then
again
clearly the
amount of powers you need to write the
sum of the fi is at most
the sum of the
powers you need to express each one and
you want to know if you can do better
can you reduce the number to the right
or are they equal and the symmetric
vector of stress and conjecture is
basically telling you that if you have
homogeneous polynomials of degree d an
independent set of variables then the
rank of the sum is the sum of the ranks
you cannot do better
so this is basically what the conjecture
is telling you
and what is difficult about trying to
prove this conjecture is that the
wearing rank is quite difficult to
compute is not easy so you cannot do
many examples but the fact is also
difficult to characterize it and the
thing you have to do
basically is to characterize the
worrying rank of each fi in such a way
you can use this characterization to
describe the rank of f so this is the
very difficult task is both to describe
the rank of a form in a nice way and to
describe the rank of a sum of forms in a
way using these
atomic elements you in some sense manage
to
achieve or to compute or to determine
okay
so
let's see something about the wearing
rank because this is what we're going to
use and how you can compute bounds on
the varying rank usually
from my point of view is not difficult
to find upper bounds what is really
difficult is to find good lower bounds
and as far as i know there are two
approaches to do this
so one approach is due to landsberg and
titler 2009
and this i think it's quite a famous
paper now in the foundation of
computational mathematics they had a
very nice idea a geometric idea of
computer rank with a lot of consequences
and we will see that
another approach which i know
is due to quite a lot of people and
there
is a very simple idea in some sense the
idea is coming from this paper of 2012
but it took a long while before jung u
and marvika talizano realized that you
can use it
in a much more efficient way basically
using the idea of 2012 we could just do
some few examples but then
especially the korean guy jung who had a
very nice idea and that is what is going
to be part of this 2014 project
and now i'd like to say something more
about the basic language if you want to
use
these techniques from my point of view
they both use a polarity theory maybe
j.m has a different
idea of what the polarity theory is
especially in 2009 it was completely
different but if you look inside it this
is what i see so i think this is the
common ground for both the two different
techniques you can use
so just a brief brief remainder of what
is a polarity theory you start with your
ring of polynomials s
and then you introduce a new polynomial
ring in new variables wise and the idea
is that you want t to act on s in a very
natural way which is by differentiation
so each variable of the ring t i see as
a differential of pareto so y i is just
a derivative with respect to x i and if
you take a monomial you just take
several
several derivatives if you take any
element in t it's just a differential
operator acting on s
and once you make these you can
attach to each polynomial homogeneous
polynomial in f it has a very nice
object which is called the purp ideal
which is basically the set of all
differential operator killing
f
and you can prove that this set is
closed under addition very easy it's
also closed under outside multiplication
so it is an ideal and it has a very nice
property but the most important one
relating it to wearing rank and
structural conjecture is the so-called a
polarity lemma
which is telling you that you can write
f as a sum of r powers of the
deaf power of linear forms if and only
if inside death perp you have a very
special ideal which is the idea of a set
of r points and this basically means
that you have your r points and you have
all the polynomials vanishing at them
and they form this nice ideal i
and this is the condition if and only if
sufficient and necessary condition to
know if you can write f
as a sum of d powers of linear form
exactly in the number of r
and it's not easy however once you have
f perp to decide what is the minimal r
set of cardinality of a set of points
such that the ideal of the set of points
is a side of purpose so is not making
your problem easier but you can use a
lot of techniques from algebraic
geometry because now you start speaking
about set of points and then you can use
liver functions and these many tools
so this is why symmetric tensor are for
me nicer to treat because you have all
this geometrical approach set up for you
and you can just play with it
so what is landsberg titler approach
well this is
my version of it so any mistake just
come from me is not what
is not default but the basic idea is
that the rank of f can be bounded by
below by one plus the dimension of sigma
s which is just the
locus of s plus one opal points of the i
per surface f equals zero so if you have
polynomial f you can look at the
geometrical object that it defines as
the zero locus
and for example if s is zero you are
just looking for the points of this
hypersurface if s is one you are looking
for singular points in which all first
partial derivatives vanish if s is two
then you're looking for second
derivatives vanishing and so on so this
is the see in some sense the singular
locus of appropriate say degree of f
and then the last summon is the
dimension of a vector space you take the
ring t you mod out by the idea of curve
everything is graded so it's a direct
sum of homogeneous pieces you just take
the s piece look at the dimension and
that number you cook up in this way is a
lower bound for the rank of f i think
this is a beautiful result also because
it's mixing
the geometrical
uh properties of f i think it's the
first time i saw anything like this with
some of this algebraic property of their
polar idea yeah
oh t is the ring of is here yeah
is the new ring with you have
differential pair the ring polynomials
in the y's which you see as differential
operators and another question is what
is s
well i think that s is part of the art
of the problem you can pick s
as you want
if you are not careful you get a very
small lower bound which is useless and
you start moving s and the lower bound
is going to increase and maybe you are
very happy because the lower bound is
equal to some upper bound you have and
then you compute the wearing rank which
is always good if you don't manage you
get a good lower bound anyway
and some applications only few
of the meaning they had are the
following so for example they managed to
compute the rank of these
two reducible forms
maybe a surprise but in 2009 it was not
known and with their method is probably
a one line proof something like that
it's just a computation
they also managed to get lower bound not
optimal too bad for them good for me
for monomials
and finally which is probably the i
think the most relevant one they managed
to get lower bank bounds for the varying
rank of the terminal and permanent of
generic messages so metis is filled with
indeterminates and i think this is the
first
result about the wearing rank about them
which was new 2009 and maybe it was
improved one or two years ago by this
student by jarobino but you see is is
probably one of the best thing
you can get from this because it was
completely unexpected at least from my
point of view and not easily improved
okay what is about this group of people
working on the project well you can use
this other approach to find a lower
bound so basically you don't look at the
geometry of the diverse hypersurface you
just look at the algebraic aspect
and you have
a lot of freedom here so from the other
perspective the freedom was the number s
from this perspective the freedom is
that you can choose your ideal eye as
you want as soon as it is generated by
linear forms and then you can pick a
linear form inside this ideal
you can perform this operation you
compute the quotient f perp colon i plus
l is a new
idea and this is what you can choose
once you have your new idea you look at
this quotient and this is a graded ring
only with finitely many non-zero uh
homogeneous pieces so you take this sum
actually this time you can say from for
any value of i but only from zero to d
plus one you have something which is not
zero you put all of these numbers
together you get a number this is a
lower bound for the very rank and again
if you are not careful yep
what happens
yeah what y plus one
so already includes everything of degree
t plus one
well this is for after d plus one you
get all zeros right
yeah so it was just a way to say you can
stop there
oh yes but it was just to say you can
stop there there's no way you have to
consider
lower than zero or bigger than d plus
one so this is enough to take the
dimension of the quotient that's a
fundamental i think
this is in red just because i was
expecting this kind of problems and in
fact it will disappear
so from this point on i will just say
sum over all values of i and all the
final number are the good ones
but mostly whatever yep and what happens
if you make a mistake like a non-general
l
then you get a number but that number is
not clear to me what is telling you
and there is which way i mean
does it overestimate underestimate or
there's no correlation so the way i say
this is that
l
maybe is a zero divisor
and then you cannot play that game
anymore yeah basically you are killing
twice the same thing yeah so you can get
a number which is too big but it's not
the good lower bound it's false
it's too big yeah
and again some applications and they are
following the same line of what we did
before so you see they are the same they
did with a equal one and b equal to but
actually with this approach you can see
that you can do much more so you can
just take any a and b but the condition
is that a plus one has to be at least b
if it is smaller well this is not
working
okay there are difficulties if a plus
one is less than d
we manage to do but only with three
variables so this means we can compute a
rank it's a nice number but in this
situation we have more than three
variables we don't manage to do if a
plus if a is too small i don't know why
yet but there should be a reason
and then we also managed to compute the
varying rank of all monomials using this
formula which by luck give the lower
bound which is equal to the natural
upper bound
and so you can prove that their rank is
very ranked exactly what you want
okay
and then
monomials i want to say something more
about monomials and you will see why
they are just an easy example but they
have something really special which is
probably not what you expect to be not
affect the fact that they factor this is
not what is special there is something
special about them and it's going to be
very relevant for the stars and
conjecture
aspects i want to show you so let's
start with the easy part so what is the
result about monomial is that the rank
is given by this nice formula you
multiply
all the exponent increased by one
the smallest the smallest you can forget
you can get these computing using the
first the previous
lower bound and an upper bound which is
pretty natural so we know the very rank
of monomials
but we also know that monomials
in different set of variables satisfy
structure and conjecture so this was
stated about coprime monomials co prime
means that if you take two of them and
you compute the gcd is equal one
since monomial factor this means no
common variable so go prime and in
different set of variables is the same
thing and in that 2012 paper we also
managed to show that the rank of the sum
is the sum of the ranks
and at the time these just look like a
very peculiar property of monomials
which was not so clear where it was
coming from now i'd like to show you
what from our point of view is the real
special property of monomials so what is
special about monomials and the best way
to see it is just to go through one
example so we compute together the
varying rank of this monomial so we
compute the purp ideal
just increase each exponent by one and
that's the perp ideal and inside this
f-perp it's clear that we can have the
we have these ideal here and from my
point of view
so
this y squared fourth power minus y zero
for power
is a collection of four distinct lines
like this
and when you look at y1 cube
like zero cube this is a collection of
three lines like this so you have this
nice grid and intersection points of
this grid
are actually
the points of the polarity lemma so in
some sense i is defining the ideal of 12
points in this precise way
and so by the polarity lemma you know
that the rank of f
is at most 12
because you can decompose it using 12
because by the polarity lemma you have a
set of 12 points the ideal of a set of
12 points distinct and then you can play
this kind of game
how do you get the lower bound well the
lower bound you can get using
the technique we showed before in a very
simple case because you don't have an
ideal i of many linear forms just one
you take the same linear form twice you
get this nice idea which is a complete
intersection of degree 12 if you want to
be sophisticated which simply means that
when you compute the sum
with no upper bound the lower bound you
see you just compute the sum you get
exactly number
12. i don't understand the notation
yeah tell me y zero plus y zero equals
that's y zero y zero
it's out of device this level ideal plus
an ideal oh the f call on the way zero
yeah
yeah yeah well it's missing but i don't
think it's really necessary here
i can write it here if you want i i
think i love that it's
okay
that's a good question you have f curve
call on the ideal way zero you get a
larger idea and then you throw ways here
inside and that's what you get yeah and
then you use that idea
to apply the lower bound formula and you
get exactly 12. and in this case it's
very easy to see why you get 12. and
it's also very easy to see why
any exponent of the lowest exponent is
not playing a game
because when you are at this level
the variable with the lowest exponent
will have always exponent equal one
and this is why in the formula i show
you for the rank of monomials
you don't have the power of
the lowest exponent appearing is going
to disappear in this way okay but now
what about stress and conjecture
well
so now we take two polynomials say
monomials the red one which is the one
we just took and the blue one is 0 a1 a2
are the our new variables
independent set of variables
and now you compute the rank of the red
one we know is
12 and the red the rank of the blue one
is 4 so if you take the sum
of these two monomials you get rank at
most 16.
oh sorry that was a stupid mistake i
made yesterday night yeah
so if you want to make this work and i'm
not trying to i won't try to give you a
nicer example than make a stupid mistake
so this is
the one we want to consider so it's
twice the same monomial
but simply with different variables i
forgot the exponent there sorry
so what you get is at most 12 plus 12
24 yeah so it's never a good idea to
make last minute changes
okay just forget that but you will see
what is important about it in just a
second
so what is important is that when you
want to perform the game we play before
so you remember that idea i
before was just y0 now is with two
generators y0 and b0
and then the linear form you pick here
is y0 plus b0 which is a general linear
form because you can rescale no
coefficients are important because you
are in different set of variables
and now if you compute you get the right
number which is not 16 but it is 24. as
a lower bound and so you manage to get
that stress and conjecture holds for the
sum of these very two precise monomial
but you see that the upper bound 24 is
easy to get it just comes from that
formula the lower bound comes from what
from the fact that you have a blue
linear form and a red linear form which
are computing the rank so this is the
crucial part of it how do you know
that's a general linear form
well this is very easy from my point of
view because just take three way zero
plus four be zero
okay
and then you can just incorporate the
coefficient
because as they are in different set of
variables the coefficient can just be
a linear incorporated of y zero and b
zero only it could be
you know y zero y one r general but if
you oh they i understand your question
but
exactly so if you go back here
l is a general linear form in i
so you cannot use anything outside i
oh oh oh you're only allowed in linear
forms in i
yeah oh it's not if you want to play
this trick yes in the way we play it
if you want to play this trick in the
way you play we play it you only allow
linear form in a yeah
so you're saying that this is this is
this statement here holds true for any i
generated bilinear forms
this is what i have in mind yes maybe
you get a number which is too small of
course you have to avoid to take
trivialities
but this is working because you
basically the more linear form you take
the less you take away so
you can take i generated by the single
linear form
this is the monomial case this is a 2012
thing if you want to compute this
formula you take one linear form
this is the example without the mistake
right the mistake is the next example
but here you use y zero
you take one linear form and you perform
it
and well the one uniform case is the
most natural but the fact is that is not
always working
so if you play
here
with only one linear form at this level
you don't get 24.
say we didn't manage to get 24 with just
one linear form and in many other
examples i will show you you need to
play with the fact that i can have many
generators not only one
and
then you must choose something inside i
of degree one yeah
oh sorry okay so this is the example and
this is what is special about monomials
is this fact here so if you have this
homogeneous polynomial you say it is
linearly computable if you can find an
ideal generated by linear forms
and
when you compute
this lower bound it's equal to the
actual value of the wearing rank so the
special thing about these forms is that
the rank can be computing in this way
and this is true for example for
monomials and this is relevant because
this is what
we realized is that if you have these
then the property of coprimonials of
satisfying structuring conjecture moves
on and it is satisfied from everything
which is linearly computable so if you
have your homogeneous polynomials in
different set of variables
and
they are also linearly computable then
the rank of the sum is the sum of the
ranks so it's just not only for
monomials
is just is true for everything having
the property of being linearly
computable so if you can compute the
rank
if you can characterize the rank it's
not that you compute it you characterize
it in a nice way
so in precisely this nice way then you
can prove
that the rank the rank of the sum when
they are in different set of variables
is the sum of the ranks so this is what
the main thing i want to show you is
this way of proving stats and conjecture
whenever you have these two properties
different set of variables
and linearly computable so now what i'm
going to do is to show you some examples
of linearly computable forms and some
problems
that arise when you want to work with
them
so the first example is
but this is just summarizing it so the
first example is nonlinear
oh that's a good question it's coming
well
i tell you is like this is the cubic
the first one i don't know how to
compute linearly
is the cubic and the 10 a line and the
tangent conic so irreducible cubic of
this form
is not um
can you just move playing this game
can you move
back backwards
you can find an idea generated by linear
forms such that for a general linear
form there
you have these property and if you want
to show that something is not really
computable you need to know
the rank
and you need to show that it's not
possible to play this game
can i just understand that the bound
that you're having
so like if you take
y q plus
x cubed plus y cubed plus length 2
polynomial and then you take your ideal
generated by d by dx
so what's your bound saying
if you want we can do that later i don't
want to enter in computation at this
precise
point we can do that immediately after
if you want
yeah perfect
one i already made a mistake in one
computation before i don't want to make
it too
if it is first let's wait how many
mistakes there are after this and then
we can do that
i just try to understand and i think you
lack assumptions
i know it's right and maybe
he's not right and phrasing but i don't
think so but we can just speak about
that you so you worry about i but i
think this is what it is
it's uh generated by linear forms yeah
and then you take the general one we can
speak about it yeah
so just to give the example of
biminomials again so you have the rank
you can write this expression you can
easily find the upper bound
as we did here basically using the same
trick
and the lower bound is coming
again in the same way using the
lowest exponent variable
so you can do this you find this
complete intersection and then you can
multiply the degrees unless n is zero
you get this number if n is zero you get
one just because your monomial is a
power so there is nothing to do and the
rank is one
and so this is linearly computable in
the most in the simplest way
another example of linearly computable
forms are
binary forms and again this is pretty
easy
so the purp idl has two generators say
degree d1 and degree d2 d1 is at most d2
and then we know there are two options
here
if g1 is square free the rank is exactly
d1 if g1 is not square free well then
the rank is d2
and if g1 is square free then what you
want to do is basically pick a linear
form which is not dividing g1
and then you play this game and the idea
you get is lg one which is a complete
intersection of the greedy one
so in the red case the rank is d1 and
the rank computing in this way is the
one so it's linearly computable
and in the blue case you have to play a
little
slightly different trick
you're just to choose l which is a
multiple factor of g one if you do that
when as soon as you have l you also have
g1 so what is left is g2 and this is the
degree of what is left
so again in this situation you see what
a problem is the problem is that i'm
able to show that it is linearly
computable because i know the rank so so
this is what i don't like up to this
level but i will hope to show you an
example in which
uh you can actually use this notion to
discover what the rank is so it's not uh
too bad but this is a problem the
problem would be
to characterize linearly computable form
without the need of knowing the rank
because knowing the rank is difficult
and then there are more examples
so for example
always this reducible form we saw before
and they are linearly computable and
also the one in which you add
the power is nearly computable
and then also the one with only three
variables now no restriction on the fact
that a must be
large enough
and again adding a variable
and there is a la well van der mauer
determines misspelled second mistake
so they are legally computable again and
i think this is coming from
your paper with your ooh i guess i is
inside there
i i got it from there so i just made a
computation that is coming from that
and then uh also this
big family which again is coming from
something i read in your paper and then
jung oh my oh explain to me
is that if you have g
and you know that the purple ideal of g
is a competitor section
maybe you don't know what the rank of g
is but if you multiply g by a linear
form which is
a new variable say a new variable then
the the form you construct in this way
you can compute the rank of it and you
know it is linearly computable
and so for example families of g such
that it is a complete intersection i
think they are this q fundamental
invariant of
reflection group of aquaponic
arrangement
so there is a big family of polynomials
of which you can
you you can use to construct example by
multiplication
okay and after this there are several
questions
so
all the examples i show you are showing
you that
are of reducible forms
so the question can be well maybe all
linearly computable forms are reducible
and this is not true
and one example is the nodal cubic
so the nodal cubic is linearly
computable but it's not reducible so
it's not true that linearly computable
means reducible
and also the converse is not true so it
is true that reducible forms are
linearly computable i don't know but i
doubt it's true
and for example the easiest example is
this reducible cubic so a line with a
conic to which the line is tangent
is reducible but we don't think it is
linearly computable
so
though there exists polynomials that are
not linearly computable say by dimension
i don't try really hard but i think that
i show you
one way
now
but the general cubic i think because
the apollo linga is too small now to get
very likely you have many examples but i
was looking for an example was easily
explained in some sense
and there is some geometry explaining it
for example
the smallest one which i think we can
show is not linearly computable
so it's the following
so
if you take anything like this so say x0
and then you have
say x1
so it's again this kind of game
so this a
and they have b powers
and if you look at this one we know that
when a plus one is more than b
we know what to do
so if a plus one
is less than b
well
maybe this is something we don't know to
do how to do explicitly but we
discovered that we can do this so we can
compute the
rank of this one
and this is basically 3b
okay so for example the smallest one we
can consider is this one so x x 0
and x 1 cubed
x 2 cubed
plus x 3 cubed
something like this
and then these you can show the rank is
nine
but the fact is that if you use the
lower bound i show you both of them what
you get is not nine the best you can get
is eight so in this situation for this f
the rank of f we know is nine
and the three so these trivial tech well
these elementary techniques only produce
that the lower bound is eight
so basically using this technique we
know that is at most nine
we know is at least eight to show that
this formula holds to show that it is
actually nine we need to play a little
bit more with these ideal with this f
perp
colon i plus l
and basically it's not just use looking
at the dimension at the inber function
you have to look more carefully to what
would mean to have rank 8 so it will
give you some equality between ideals so
you get some
nice property and you can show that well
eight is not possible and the same trick
carries on here to show that it is 3b
and this one is another example
which i pretty convinced we can show is
not linearly computable
and the idea why this is not linearly
computable is kind of nice
and the fact is that you can
so you have that polynomial there and we
know the rank is uh nine so
there is some a polar ideal so some uh
scheme zero dimensional scheme of
nine points sitting there and the fact
that is that you can always find some of
this scheme with a very nice shape
which means that you have the three
lines so say
x one
equal x two equals zero and x one equal
x three equals 0
and x 2
equal x 3 equals 0. so among all these
schemes
of nine points having this property
there are some
like this
so nicely organized
three lines and on each line you have
three and the fact is that you can move
the points
back and forth so basically each point
of this line will be a point of an
apollo
sub-scheme of nine points
so a scheme you can use to decompose f
and now if you pick your
uh
l
in any way
you can move these points in such a way
that l will contain at least one so this
is the plane l equals zero it will
contain one of these points so basically
if you use i equal the idea of l when
you compute that colon ideal you lower
the rank
so the best lower rank you can get using
our technique is eight so this is why i
believe
refining this argument you can show that
this form is not linearly computable
and the geometric reason is that pick
your l i can move the points they are
still a polar one point is going to be
deleted
and when you play that game you cannot
exceed the cardinality of this set of
points so you can always get at most
eight but the rank is nine so you cannot
compute the rank and the form is not
linearly computable so this is just one
example about
and i think that we
are almost over yep
okay so
thank you
okay um further questions where we go
question is that is that statement
you're not uh known for you know the
symmetric
you know warring right is it is that
conjecture known for
the moderate symmetric bordering
worrying about what i mean the strassen
part yeah i don't know about that
actually i don't think so
so it's not known to be false it's not
known to be false not let's say pretty
sure it's not known to be false yeah
we've been using these for tensors which
are not symmetric and to well
to prove better uh lower bound to you
just prove common questions i think we
never tried about it i don't know
actually i never thought about that
about going back to tensors no i don't
know yeah
this is very special about polynomials
because you play with a lot of this
commutative algebra which is special of
homogeneous forms
different questions
yes okay so this is for the complex one
right yeah what happens it that we in
the real run case do we lose my question
also exactly the same okay that's they
have a very easy answer which is i have
no idea because i never considered that
yeah
so is
just play with the complex numbers yeah
everything is there because it's easier
for us i don't say is needed
but this is what we are using
do we know it i mean
it's
much different from what's in computers
but for monomials i know a little bit in
the binary case is different so if you
have monomials in two variables the
real rank can be larger and we know
exactly how large is the sum of the
exponent rather than
the largest plus one but if you have
more than three more than two variables
i have no idea even for monomials and
what i can tell you is that when you
compute for monomials this expression
usually you have a lot of complex
coefficient appearing
so i would expect is going to be larger
but i cannot tell you how large more how
larger is going to be
for two variables we know because it's
very easy but just three i don't think
is known
do you know if it's true for border
ranking the results that you have are
linearly computable
actually i don't know maybe luca was
thinking about it but i don't know
not in that extent in
special cases you can
probably use some kind of trick but
not that
if i can add one one comment
is that of course you can strengthen the
conjecture scene
except for realities you may ask if all
possible decal positions
come from the decomposition of f and
decomposition of g
which is stronger and in that case
probably you need some new idea because
the reduction that you get
is not
maybe that you don't get all possible
decompositions of that i mean the
clearing side of all possibility
composition so there's still a lot of
space to
explode
same question
for cactus wrong
oh yeah
but the answer is the same which i don't
know
i know it's boring but
it
your lower bound equals the wearing rank
and the cactus rank and border rank are
smaller so
this
is not a lower bound for those cactus
and border rank
no i think the question is if a cactus
rank is additive
yeah just draw some conjecture for
characters right yeah
sure
so for monuments we know
okay well uh there are a lot of great
questions and uh before we break i
wanted to
remind you of something you may have
gotten on an email no
so there's a website for where you can
post these kind of questions that you're
asking that no one knows the answer to
yet so here's the website
www.ocf.berkeley.org
and then
peermason
okay so here's the idea so uh
there have been many great open
questions presented and the last time i
mentioned this at a previous conference
i said if you have a very large box that
has a computer in it and you could ask
it one question
what question would you ask so that's
problem type number one for instance
what's the the s rank of two by two
matrix multiplication that's on the list
and uh then the lower on the wiki is
general open questions if you would like
to submit an open question which is not
computable by a large computer
and if you're really afraid of wikis
uh you can feel free to just email me
your question and i will be very happy
to post it to the wiki um but i would be
very happy if you guys can help
contribute to the list of open problems
related to this workshop so thanks and
then we'll meet back again at 3 50.
thank you